yeah plumber javier was down at the
alternate site this is his first big
league start in a couple of weeks but
that was all by design we understand
david fletcher shohei ohtani and mike
trout for the visiting angels
the strikeout for javier
two strikeouts start the game for
christian javier
pretty nasty change-up i'm actually kind
of curious to see this matchup between
christian javier who has that good
fastball in the upper portion of the
zone
jared walsh has the reputation of being
very good on hitting the fastball and
driving it gets a lot of swings
underneath just like that
three strikeouts nothing comes to the
two-out walk underway in houston tonight
it's alex cobb on the mound for the
third time as an angel
33-year-old right-hander going back to
work on alex bregman now who takes the
first pitch out to right field and drops
it in for a base hit and here's your don
alvarez
no
or was it and one that just caught too
much of the plate
first and third with two guns so a
little two-out micro rally developing
here for houston now it's julie gurio
i lost him with another knuckle curve
and that has loaded the bases
huge opportunity for kyle tucker
there's one a good one that he makes
tucker swing over the top of so the
strikeout gets him out of a bases loaded
two-out jam we go to the second
scoreless in houston christian javier
issued a two-out walk in the first but
did register three strikeouts
and that's four strikeouts for javier
two gone and five strikeouts for
christian javier
christian javier mix in a ground out
dude
all six
via the swinging strikeout
hooks the ball into left field and
that'll bound up against the corner
first extra base hit of the night oh and
diaz is able to stay on the bag
what the mary lou retton is going on out
there
top of the file for why you have to
stretch to play pro sports kids and
here's miles straw now
sharply hit past the third baseman rojas
into the corner that's going to get diaz
around to score
miles straw driving in the first run of
the night and it's one nothing astros
a ball into the short left field corner
then he turns into a triple
two balls and two strikes to correa
and a ground ball that trickles through
the infield and allows straw to score
easily boy that's a two-strike count
that
just got away from cobb
big plate appearance here for yuli
guriel
the astros would love to take further
advantage of what has been an inning
where they're runners on base throughout
if base is loaded here's the 3-2 pitch
and he just missed with the split change
man didn't miss by much
an rbi for guriel is team leading ninth
three nothing astros
kyle tucker a strikeout victim to end
the first
and that's lined into cello right where
fletcher had him played perfectly to
avoid any further damage
and suzuki finally succumbs to the
strikeout that's seven for javier here's
david fletcher
and fletcher chases to strike out
oh there we go
boy that's a ball that's
four inches in on his hands and carlos
correa lines it into center well flips
it into center for an rbi base hit what
a fine job at the plate by carlos correa
four-nothing astros
boy this is played right into dusty
baker's hands now
brantley the runner at second after his
sixth double of the year already
bregman lines that in the left field and
the whole thing is blown up two runs
will score and the astros take a
commanding six-nothing
lead man he got hit in the elbow and i
don't know that that got there's no pad
there i don't think
he has a little protection there right
around the tricep barry but that looked
like he got it right in the
i thought it elbow a slider dude oh
really dude i can't pick up the ball
here though
his stuff is his stuff looks like that
too
yeah owen won the count to miles straw
oh michael bourne very fast on the
ground hot shot for rojas recovers and
gets diaz at second
but scoring easily from third is kyle
tucker and it's seven nothing houston
mike trout has come out of the ball game
after being hit in the elbow a couple of
innings ago tried to stick around scott
shebler has taken over in center field
for him the angels are calling it a left
elbow contusion and as painful as that
word may be it's certainly better than
the alternative
here's alex bregman now he's been on
base in all three of his plate
appearances tonight two singles and he
was hit by a pitch in the second
add another base hit man he and correa
are going nuts at the top of this order
carlos is going to score
and the astros are on the board again
pujols to right field that's got a
chance if it stays fair and that one's
gone
albert pujols to the opposite field to
get the angels on the board in the sixth
wait a minute wait a minute all boundary
calls are reviewable yeah it's gonna
stand you
[Laughter]
know yeah it's got to feel good to get
back home in front of their home fans
hear the cheering
and to put up a big number here at home
they haven't done that yet yet this year
that'll do it with an exclamation point
and a 95 mile an hour fastball
ryan presley remains perfect to start
the year
and the astros post an 8-2 victory at
home
congratulations to dusty baker we talked
about how he was
on the doorstep of the 1900 club
he enters access tonight
14th on the all-time wins list with his
1900th
managerial win tonight